[Music]
jason derulo anybody the real law fan
yeah you know it's pretty cool just like
a pop singer yeah i got like really
really really huge during the pandemic
because tick tock started blowing up
yeah oh yeah and he [ __ ] went ham on
tick tock killed it yeah he's collab
with everybody yeah still killing it
[ __ ] really i feel like he made more
off a tick tock than he did ever before
but it's just funny because it's vegas
jason rule gets into a fight at a las
vegas club after a man calls him usher
oh yeah oh my god compliment
i mean if someone's called usher say
that to jason i wouldn't be that mad
everyone's just going to call this guy
asher forever now
yeah because he made a big deal out of
it yeah that's a [ __ ] compliment dude
why do you get so mad where are you
gonna fight somebody they're like hey
what's up usher
i'm sure there's gotta be some other
random contest frank hates loving this
club he's like
[Laughter]
i'm surprised steve knows that i know
dude like out of nowhere name a second
one name a second one oh yeah
[Applause]
yeah las vegas police were called to the
strip resort uh in the early hours of
tuesday morning and said derulo
committed battery against two
individuals two he [ __ ] went
he's a big guy though isn't he he's a
big guy he's tall there's a video of it
right
is there i was trying to look for some
video i couldn't find that yeah there's
a video and in the video it looks like
when the guy starts calling him usher
and [ __ ] because he also says [ __ ] you
[ __ ] so there's also that he goes like
hey ashley [ __ ] you [ __ ]
i think it like that's that's pretty
funny it was the result they can't write
that part in the article yeah
it was a result of some other
altercation that happened all right the
whole thing he's like omg is way too
loud dude
because it makes him look like the bad
guy where he could have been the good
guy yeah but some [ __ ] had already
happened and he was that guy was yelling
that as a response to whatever took
place so i don't know yeah i love that
ryan knows everything here we go oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i followed my jason drools
wait where are they surrounding him
or they're just talking to him to
escalate oh why they opened his face
like that
are they at the top where are they
that's already a funny video let's fight
down here that's what they said
[Music]
he wants to [ __ ] comment
dude that guy is way too little to be
talking to just a girl like that
oh
wait you know what i think i'm a jason
derulo i kind of like it i kind of like
it i'm also an usher fan jason a little
pretty badass
dude yeah i'm a big fan of people saying
[ __ ] you and getting smacked
people that talk [ __ ] man i like it when
they get smacked in the face it makes me
so happy what was the point of that like
what was the point of saying hey hey hey
a [ __ ] you usher
cause he recorded him going all the way
up and then going down it just seems
like instigate out of nowhere right i
mean honestly dude this is a big thing
with athletes and with celebrities like
where people are trying to get to them
[ __ ] yeah
it's a big thing for nfl players nba
players like people just trying to pick
fights with them yeah i don't like when
people when like uh nba games where
people on this like in the front row
just talking mad [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you like
they'll say rude [ __ ] they can get
kicked out right like the one without
brawn right yeah they were telling
lebron like i hope your kids die
they said that's a russell westbrook
they're like dude i hope your kids die
and they said that's isaiah thomas one
time and it's like dude like you should
be punching the [ __ ] head because
that was the one where the baby
escorted him i escorted them out and i
was surprised like he had enough like
composure to not just start swinging
they're trying to like hey man we're a
part of the game that's our team and
then they think they're getting into
their head to like be it's entitlement
you feel like you're affecting them so
you have power over them and then you're
like yeah he lost that game because me
life yeah then they could have beers
with the boys and [ __ ] like you know
what happened i got to his [ __ ] head
told him his [ __ ] kids they would die
that's why they lost the game man
they're trying to be spike lee when they
get kicked out like that do they get
banned like you just can't come back i
don't know
can you talk [ __ ] about space jam 2
though yeah to lebron like i think
lebron knows yeah it's like hey dude
this basically chooses kind of whack i
hope your kids are okay but i freaked
out a rotten tomatoes spore sheet
yeah do you even need to say anything
but just
space jam too
too dude yeah that was [ __ ] up it was
[ __ ] up let him be his old man you
weren't a very good dad till the end
that's a good burn so that's really good
that gets in his [ __ ] head then he's
like oh man he's right
so at the time the two victims did not
want to press charges but there's always
the possibility of a lawsuit because a
lawyer is going to reach out and be like
guys
you should be gaining money for this
sure either way here's the thing they
have up to one year to change their
minds and move forward with one year you
have a year to press charges you don't
need that much time you should it should
be like four weeks tops eight months
from now they're like broke they're like
[ __ ] it i need money like what
[ __ ] pride no everybody forgets anyway
might as well get the money people are
going to talk him into doing like
maybe it's time to sue
that's an easy one right jason because
he comes running at him like you just
say i don't know where he's pretty bad
he's got a trespassing notice jason
drillo did from arya and was removed
from the property what he's passing i
think it's because he threw the first
punches and stuff because they told him
they talked about the antagonizers man i
think people that just verbally assault
other people yeah like should get kicked
out too especially in this case when
there's an actual clear video of what
happened well for the most part well
plus we we don't i mean you know i'm not
a scientist so we don't understand what
actually happens to human psyche when
someone gets called usher that's true
when you're adjacent to rules
when you're in this industry you should
just try it out start calling people
usher see what happens maybe it really
does tip
unless you're at a theater and that guy
really is an usher oh that's bad that's
true then it's literally jason
he'll [ __ ] you up hey [ __ ] you jason
gorilla
hey [ __ ] jason
yeah you can't do that that's like you
on fire in the movie theater you beat
you with a velvet rope
well still got the [ __ ] hook and gold
chain at the end dude that's gonna hurt
damn i've never been called usher before
so i don't know how that feels hey [ __ ]
you usher i've been called boy
watch out man
he's boiling okay okay okay good to know
yeah dude
i've been called wong fu before it's
really hurt my feelings oh man have you
been called fung brothers yeah doesn't
hurt my feelings i'm sick okay i was in
a long food video and it hurt my
feelings
because for me i think i'm like we gotta
call jab walking yesterday yeah dude i'm
like and then asked to get subsequently
is that racist
you're the one that's tripping i'm like
doesn't affect me yeah at least she
asked oh the [ __ ] up my bad i was
wearing the jabberwocky shirt and mask
and the hat yeah but so are a lot of
people but
so were the rest of the jama crew
i we i was once uh going through tsa and
then uh this lady was like oh you guys
are the jack milwaukees right to us in
the crew and then they let us in to like
uh tsa pre-check
to like go like faster so we didn't say
anything
wow that's tight absolutely you gotta
use it you gotta use it the name
jabbawockeez is so worldwide though yeah
it's like you get so many perks if
you're in vegas like you're worldwide
you know what i mean because my airliner
you guys would have to sit with the
luggage dude
you're with the jabberwock easier you
gotta say what the [ __ ] luggage dude
we're we're in the back with the
chickens and [ __ ] [ __ ] rambles on the
side but you're here too
got the chickens and the pigs and the
nuggets a cargo
plane he's like it's about to get cold
and the [ __ ] jabberwockies comes up
and gives us a [ __ ] sweater that we
can wear that's a jabba shirt
[Laughter]
we're all [ __ ] shivering with the
jabberwock he's in the back like [ __ ]
why did we say we were jabberwockies on
[ __ ] steve airways man
stevenwood
you like them dancers it was like one
bit
green air
green air
damn name steve name is jason gorilla
song jason's rules song ah dude i'm out
i don't know either but i know it plays
all the time in this club i know there's
a song where he says his name at the
beginning of the song jason derulo
that's all i really know all i have a
few of them only what's the jason jewell
song didn't he redo what you say
oh did he
what to say
yeah yeah
but yeah but then like turn it into like
kind of like a r b ish oh
he sampled i don't really remember to be
coming so you don't even know you have
the [ __ ] computer you could have
googled that
i want you to want me is the only one i
can how does that go
no no no of course it's got to play it
on dude
yeah he redid savage love that's what
also made it tiktok popular because that
like ended up being a tick-tock popular
song what savage love i don't even know
the original how's
yeah i hated that one you could you
could literally sound that out for
anyone in the world they'll go i hate
that song
do
that's the other jason derulo
[Music]
my
[Music]